fifty percent of americans now carry
some form of medical debt up from 46
last year the stats released by consumer
financial company debt.com
say 57 of those who have medical debt
owe at least one thousand dollars
this is driven mostly by diagnostic
tests
hospitalizations and emergency room
visits debt collectors hold about 140
million dollars in medical debt which
does not include credit card balances
and unpaid medical bills that haven't
hit consumer credit reports
if you add those factors in
americans may actually owe as much as 1
trillion dollars in medical debt unlike
other forms of consumer debt medical
bills are hard to predict and prevent
even for people with insurance
since many consumers are not prepared to
absorb their health care costs medical
debt can be hard to collect which then
makes it particularly inexpensive on the
debt market one debt reduction
non-profit rip medical debt told forbes
on average it can buy 100 of medical
debt for one dollar
this also has some individuals beginning
to negotiate their own debt personally
34 of respondents surveyed about their
medical debt by debt.com this year
said they successfully negotiated their
own medical debt compared to 27
in 2020
you